you had this idea to take me to this Spa
this Korean spa here in La so I took you
up on it and I don't I think once a week
maybe or once every two weeks people
come up to me and they love it and I
have a lot of Koreans that come up that
know that you and I went to Korea
together and it's been this gift because
um it wasn't intentional we just did it
because it we knew you knew you said oh
my God if I bring this tall red-haired
woman to a spa and
um and these women walk on his back and
he has to get in a freezing plunge pool
and stuff this is just gonna be yeah uh
funny and it was it was really
delightful and it holds up nicely after
all this time but it also helped me
appreciate how much I loved going and
checking out other cultures and me being
the joke you know what I mean I enjoyed
putting myself in situations in other
countries where I'm the odd man out yeah
and they're kind of laughing at me and I
don't quite get it and
um I mean I think if we hadn't we did
that remote and then we ended up going
to Korea together and it was such you
know we were improvising a lot we were
on buses we were exhausted yeah yeah we
were also dealing with uh social media
in uh in in South Korea so
hypersensitive yeah I mean they love you
but then if you do one thing that they
they can feel slighted but then if you
do one other thing to correct that then
they love you again and
um I remember you were helping us
navigate
don't do that okay well here's the rub
though I think part of the reason why
and I'm just kind of coming to this now
that maybe those
those remotes and like those uh bits
kind of worked was also I was incredibly
unreliable yes
like I was
you
yeah like it wasn't like an interpreter
and you it was like a fallible
unreliable
a guide that is mostly American also
going along but like the the gays of
that country would reflect off of me a
little differently than you and you
could notice that really what do you
mean I mean from if you watch it I think
you can notice it until you get to that
point where you're like hey um what is
this dish and I'm like I have no clue
I don't know I kept forgetting that wait
a minute you're a Canadian guy who went
to Michigan
much as you're a South Korean but I was
like there's a lot of times I'll make
Steven tell us about this wonderful
ritual and you're like I have no idea I
don't know no one explained this yeah
yeah I'll explain the Detroit Pistons
lineup to you but I can't help you with
what this monk is saying right now we
had an amazing moment we went to you and
I got in a bus with my crew and we drove
and drove and drove and drove and we got
to the like this beautiful mountain top
I remember it was cold it was cold in
South Korea
um and like an idiot I was like right it
gets cold I remember that from Mash
there were episodes where they were cold
Conan come on not everything is 1970s TV
no no I remember major Burns shivering
and eating a blanket so yes it gets cold
in Korea but
um it was really cold and we went to the
top of this mountain and there was a
monastery and you and I went and there
was it was so I mean it really looked
the part right it's very spiritual place
and they took us through and they were
teaching us how to meditate and pray and
bow and we were you know uh these monks
just seemed like they had found the
answer and remember thinking they
figured it out they figured out the
answer and then at one point we had a
break in shooting and one of the monks
was gesturing me he didn't speak English
but he's like he wanted to show me
something he took me out back and he
showed me their their massive satellites
for streaming content it was just this
mess
and then I was like what do you watch
they were like oh breaking bad you know
you know two phones she had an iPhone
and a Samsung yes he had an iPhone one
phone rang and he was like darn phone he
went to switch it off because I thought
when I read this once I leave this
Temple I shall I shall throw away my
phone because and then
and the and the monk is like damn it and
he reaches in and turns off one of his
phones but it's the wrong phone
and then I see he's playing you know
some game on you know he's he's building
his uh Sims World I don't know but uh it
was a really great experience and funny
and
I like
um I like experiences that humble me and
I'm I've noticed that you know whether
it's us going to the spa or us going to
Korea it's just I I liked and I think
we're similar that way we both yeah
could tell that we didn't quite know it
was going on yeah we didn't quite fit in
this environment yeah and uh yet that
was sort of the fun of it that was the
charge